Chris waters here with a gamespot news
update at this year's e3 publisher
Bethesda will be hosting their very own
press conference for the first time and
that means some big announcements are in
store hopefully the only games currently
on Bethesda's slate are the elder
scrolls online and doom 4 which is now
just going as doom of course rumors of
another fallout have been circulating
for about two years and many people were
disappointed that there was no fallout 4
announcement at last year's e3 and then
there's always the possibility of
another Elder Scrolls which considering
the popularity of Skyrim wouldn't be
much of a surprise although isn't it a
bit too soon the company announced that
they'll be hosting their press
conference on sunday jun 14th a day
ahead of microsoft's traditional opening
press conference fallout 4 would be
pretty awesome but i'm also pulling for
Dishonored 2 or whatever dishonored er
they want to call the sequel to
Dishonored cuz i want another dishonored
game what would you most like to see out
of bethesda press conference let us know
in the comments below and as always
check out gamespot com / news for all
your gaming news